Eric have you ever shaved a head before
no I've never cut hair I've never used
cutting utensils so I feel very prepared
[Laughter]
whoa oh my god that's so much hair it's
all going I started growing out my hair
in January 2017
I had this rad bleached blonde hair and
I didn't really want to lose it I was
like you know I'm just gonna grow it up
about a year into growing my long hair I
had the idea of growing it longer to
donate it so that's why today we are
here to shave my head to donate to
children with hair loss it's an amazing
charity that donates wigs to kids with
alopecia leukaemia chemotherapy any
medical hair loss and it gives them wigs
helps give them confidence if I can help
give a kid confidence that's pretty rad
so I'm interested to see what's gonna be
like to have a shaved head it's
definitely gonna be different but I'm
ready to say goodbye to my luscious
locks Eric you ready chop the locks
yes so what we need to do is we need to
section off like braids so you'll want
to like comb and collect the hair
together and then we got these little
dudes these small little guys it's like
once you've collected the hair I got you
bro oh we don't need this yes I'm an
expert when you donate hair they are
asking for braids and it's easier friend
there separate the hair out if it's in a
bunch of different brains
how many we're gonna have to do and then
you'll snip the braids Oh God even just
saying it makes me so anxious you'll
snip the braids this is hurt no it's
fine
yeah you want to just like collect the
hair create good braids and then you'll
snip it right at the scalp and then we
shave it is this good I can't see
anything Megan is it good that's not a
confident yeah
[Music]
Oh Oh Eric you hit a saucepot I love
getting my hair braids really my friend
Ali would French braid my hair whenever
we'd hang out we'd have a braid repaid
it's a braid braid now that I've done
such a great job with these little
braids we're gonna cut them off oh my
gosh this is actually happening Mike I'm
scared I don't even know how to cut this
do I cut from the back are you cutting
my entire head huh wait can I see Wow
oh wow yeah you're going deep I don't
know how much hair you got left now
there did I create a bald spot for you I
don't know here goes back at spies for
the kids it's for the kids got another
one bro you got an actual ponytail now
yeah this definitely is not eight inches
no I don't know no it's kind of nice oh
it's like a dog that like just comes
like a moment yeah yeah huh it's like
one of those dogs that like Jess like
just got picked off the street and
they're gonna like make it look better
in one of those you're saying I'm the
before dog in an ass I see a video
huh let's see how long the hair is
biggest braid is 12 inches holy crap two
inches 12 inches
even short one is 10 inches 144 inches
of hair Wow huh I guess now it's time to
shave my head I'm just gonna trust him
and I will regret those words later but
without further ado let's shave the head
you made it black I like the big can't
see me anymore
that's the point oh damn so they have no
idea what I'm doing right now because I
don't have any idea what you're doing
right now they can't tell that I've just
shaved your entire head off oh this goes
oh my god
that's way shorter than I thought walk
out peeler like Clark you look like [ __ ]
I'm gonna feel so responsible you're
supposed to go against the thing well oh
my god that's so much hair it's all gone
just no you look like the penguin from
that Surf's Up
it feels even and presentable to me and
so short it's time for the reveal three
two one Wow completely different person
huh looks good I love it
Eric whoa we did it did I'm so happy
this looks so good let's see what people
say about my haircut not knowing I did
it Eric shaved it it was fantastic
yeah I subscribe for mation Friday
good
yes different yes good so there's my
hair 44 inches gonna mail it off to
Michigan and it's gonna help a kid in
need be curious to see how the hair gets
processed and turned into a wig we made
an awesome video a couple years ago it's
gonna be down in the description Eric
what do you does I'm happy we donated
and we did a good thing I am genuinely
though this disappointed in my skill but
like I feel like I I feel like I should
have done better
I gotta go mail his hair off see in the
next video no give me my air bag man I
mail